[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour ce nouveau
débat consacré aux élections municipales
après mon show et bonne direction la
nièvre ce soir avec les candidats encore
en lice à cosne sur loire avec nous ce
soir l'ensemble des têtes de listes
encore en lice pour ce second tour du 28
juin prochain michel de nos bons soirs
soit vous êtes le maire sortant de cosne
sur loire il faudrait dire qu en cours
sur loire pour être précis candidat à
votre propre succession vous mener une
liste classé à droite arrivé en tête
avec 34 9% des suffrages au premier tour
daniel gilles ollier bonsoir bonsoir
vous êtes tête de liste arrivée en
seconde position candidat à la mairie
pour la première fois la tête d'une
liste sans étiquette et vous est donc
arrivé en seconde position avec 31 8%
des suffrages
alain bernier bonsoir mon sport votre
liste de gauche est arrivé troisième de
ce premier tour avec 23 7 % des
suffrages la particularité c'est que
vous avez déjà était maire de la commune
de 2008 à 2014 le quatrième homme de
cette élection c'est michel mézy qui
auraient pu figurer fusionner mais ça
n'a pas été le cas
il n'a pas donné de consigne de vote à
ses 9,6 pour cent d'électeurs alors
difficile
évidemment comme chaque soir de débuter
ce débat sans évoquer cette période de
quinze semaines que nous avons traversée
entre le premier et le second tour nous
n'avions pas réalisé de débats au
premier tour à cosne sur loire mais vous
vous avez fait campagne il y a eu un
premier tour vous êtes arrivés tous les
trois au second tour mais il n'y a
jamais eu de second tour enfin en tous
les cas pas avant le 28 juin prochain
michel garnier comment vous avez vécu
cette période de quinze semaines l'or
jusqu'à présent je m'appelle alain
dherbier à la barre c'est parce que j'y
ai moi c'est pas grave
cette période je les ai vécus comme
beaucoup de français malheureusement
inquiétante mais si vous voulez je suis
pas resté inactif
j'estime que dans une période telle que
celle que nous avions traversé il
fallait aider
ses concitoyens alors j'ai été contacté
très rapidement par des personnels
soignants qui m'ont fait part de leur
inquiétude parce qu'ils avaient un
manque de protection individuelle
requise est prêt et préconisé dans le
cadre d'une épidémie telle que celle ci
et puis j'ai aussitôt alerté le maire de
colle je les appelais en lui disant j'ai
connaissance d'un stock de masques qui
est entreposé à l'hôpital et je pense
que ça peut être utile
il m'a dit en janvier parce que vous
aviez été maire de la commune j'ai été
maire de la commune et donc président du
conseil d'administration à l'époque il
m'a dit connaître cette existence et il
a ajouté que la grèce était consciente
et qu'ils avaient réquisitionné les
masques pour l'est et pour la ville de
nevers
alors ça c'est évidemment un peu aussi
ses candidats mais c'est aussi l'ancien
maire qui parle
daniel gillot nier vous vous n'avez pas
été élu auparavant
comment vous avez vécu cette période un
peu particulière pour tout le monde
alors il est clair que le 17 mars je
dirais la vie la vie en général
d'ailleurs s'est mis entre parenthèses
donc je voudrais quand même avoir une
pensée pour pour les gens qui ont perdu
un proche pendant cette période et puis
aussi à tous les gens qui ont participé
je dirais les professions à risques
alors on apprend par le trait d'ailleurs
à juste titre des professions médicales
paramédicales et il faut aussi penser à
tous ces magasins où ces services qui
sont restés ouverts
et puis aussi quelque part aux
instituteurs ou professeurs ou leur
profession était revalorisé pendant
cette période alors pour ma part pour ma
part j'ai pas de mandat d'élu municipal
ai je donc j'ai pas été j'ai pas été
contacté par par la municipalité
c'est un regret ça qu'on dans certaines
communes par exemple le maire et ses
opposants qui sont tous les trois
finalement candidat ou tous les quatre
candidats au second tour se sont
entendus pour mener des actions communes
dans d'autres pas du tout est ce qu est
ce que vous auriez souhaité qu'il ya
quelque chose d'entre deux tours 6e
c'est tendre la main je veux dire c'est
pas un regret je pense que c'était
c'était une crise
une crise importante une crise inédite
quelque chose qui arrivait rapidement où
il fallait rapidement trouver des
solutions et où je dirais le lot
responsable de gestion si je peux dire
le patron était le maire moi aujourd'hui
je n'ai pas de commentaire à faire sur
la manière dont a été géré cette crise
vous pourriez à je pourrais ça participe
de la campagne mais non mais je veux
dire que dans ces périodes là on a
besoin on a besoin d'unité
on a besoin d'être d'être serré pour que
les choses se passent bien pour être au
service des gens
donc je n'aurai pas de commentaire à
faire sur ces sujets là ça m'aurait soit
le jeu 10 semblait inconvenant et
respectueux de vouloir me mettre en
avant uniquement pour des raisons
électorales michel venons j'imagine que
vous vous attendiez entre le premier et
le second tour a expédié les affaires
courantes puisqu'il se passe en général
une semaine et là vous avez eu à gérer
une crise sanitaire ça a changé votre
quotidien de mère tout à fait ça a
changé mon quotidien et autour de moi
j'avais une équipe restreinte d'élus et
des services aussi qu'ils étaient très
très ça nous avons mis en place le plan
de sauvegarde tout de suite
quelques jours après nous avons ensuite
essayé à la dernier m'a appelé pour les
masques on a travaillé ensemble pour
j'ai contacté tous les élus les gens les
comités de quartier les gens qui étaient
susceptibles de pouvoir nous aider pour
justement mettre en oeuvre cette
distribution de masques et autres
actions que l'on mène un ccas aussi qui
a travaillé vraiment pour nos aînés on a
plus de 100 personnes qui sont
concernées par le plan de sauvegarde
et tout ceci nous a permis d'être plus
proche des gens qui étaient vraiment
dans le besoin et c'est pas facile c'est
une période très difficile très
prenantes nous étions pas nombreux mais
je crois qu'il fallait pas trop nombreux
complots mairie c'était les règles de
sanitaires qu'ils farrell les respecter
et bon cette crise on l'a vécu comme il
le fallait et on assume et humblement
comme on devait le faire comme chaque
élu
de france a dû le faire à son niveau
mais tout ceci pour vous dire que
c'était difficile à ce qui était
compliqué pour nous c'est quand on a
commandé les masques quand on la
fabrication avec les bénévoles s'est
très bien passé l'association que
préside alain dherbier donc à participer
et mes cd commande qu'on a eues avec les
particuliers et les entreprises après
c'est la région qui nous a dépannés en
dernier moment et on a eu trois semaines
de retard pour un problème à cesser dit
compliqué cette et stressant quand même
pour tous les gens qui se sont investis
à un avion on a entendu pas de polémique
dans cet entre-deux-tours un peu
particulier où l'heure était à la crise
sanitaire est ce que cependant on
constate et pâques mais forcément le la
main est au maire sortant dans ces
circonstances-là et eybens et même si
vous avez été associé il distribue des
masques il est en première ligne comme
en ce moment vous avez vécu des choses
que vous avez l'impression qu'il y a des
gens qui continuent à faire campagne ou
bien alors pour moi si vous voulez
j'estime que dans la période que nous
traversions il faut oublier ces
différences est vraiment mettre tout en
oeuvre pour aider les personnes en
difficulté vous avez l'impression que
c'est ce qui s'est passé je pense que en
partie c'est ce qui s'est passé c'est
pourquoi comme comme le dit michel
renault moi j'ai mis à disposition un
atelier de couture dans une entreprise
adaptée dont je suis le président pour
la confection de masques et ensuite j'ai
prêté main forte pour pouvoir distribuer
les masques aux administrés je pense que
de toute façon tout citoyen en par
ailleurs dès l'instant qu'il a la
possibilité de le faire doit absolument
oeuvre et pour venir en aide
faire des commissions avec des personnes
voisine c'est qu'ils ont des difficultés
pour sortir alors qu'il fallait avoir un
papier qui y valider votre sortie
j'estime que pour les personnes âgées
c'était quelque chose qu'on pouvait
faire et et que j'ai fait qu'on a
l'impression que cet entre deux tours
s'est passé dans une bonne entente vous
dirai la même chose daniel gillot nier
oui non mais je veux dire il fallait une
solidarité de tout le monde moi pour ma
part le 17 mars j'étais encore en
activité en entreprise
donc je dirais j'ai fait tout ce qu'un
chef d'entreprise doit faire quand son
entreprise est fermée tous les papiers
toutes les demandes de chômage partiel
toutes ces choses là quelque part je
pense que ma place était plus là de
manière à ce qu'une entreprise de 20
personnes tentées redémarre un mois ou
un mois et demi plus tard mais plus gros
problèmes de trésorerie ni de problèmes
de finances
nous étions confinés metz qui avait
quand même un semblant de vie citoyenne
parce qu'il ya on ya une élection en
cours
alors moi je vais vous dire j'ai un
petit bémol j'ai un petit bémol c'est
très bien qu'on soit tous d'accord et
tous tous solidaires j'ai un petit bémol
se re comment je pourrais dire le
l'utilisation un petit peu électorale
qui a eu de fait sur deux choses sur une
distribution sur une deuxième
distribution de masques qui a eu lieu
début juin
ok en porte à porte et aussi sur un
numéro de caunes actu qui je veux dire
qui est un petit peu à la gloire de ce
qui a été fait vous avez oublié ces
derniers d'ailleurs parce que d'habitude
de position a toujours le droit à un
petit mot sur connect u donc bon c'est
des choses que j'ai trouvé un petit peu
un petit peu maladroite
bon ça m'a pas choqué plus que ça la
position
j'en veux pas monsieur le maire il faut
savoir que peut me disais tout à l'heure
le maire c'était celui qui était exposé
après les caunois les cours soient si si
ça s'est bien passé lui en seront
reconnaissants ce qui est logique ça me
choque pas vous êtes en campagne je suis
en compagnie ici lui lui sont
reconnaissants ils vont voter pour lui
c'est eux qui choisiront seniors
messieurs qui choisiront jeu je pense
qu'on peut pas non plus on peut pas non
plus basé un vote sur simplement les
trois mois aux quatre mois qu'on vient
de passer je veux dire
monsieur le maire monsieur derbier leur
mandat ont duré six ans donc voilà ils
sont un avantage sur moi c'est qu'ils
ont chacun un bilan à défendre alors
peut-être que l'on retient plus ce qui
s'est passé les six derniers mois quand
on est citoyen que ce qui s'est passé
les six dernières années des fois ça
arrive peut-être michel venu au cal est
votre point de vue est ce que forcément
comme vous étiez en première ligne gars
c'est vous qu'on a plus vu que les
autres peut-être y compris dans ses
porte à porte pour distribuer à l'image
de les deux réflexions ont été faites
sur la distribution des matches de
l'élite à là on avait trois semaines de
retard sur les livraisons la région
c'était le 8 mai on les a eus 28 voilà
de quoi bon après on peut dire ce qu'on
veut parce que ma première idée c'était
de distribuer les masques au début avant
qu'on nous annonce que les clientèles 28
c'est ça ma première idée vous pouvez
demander à tous mes collaborateurs y
avoir un deuxième tour tout
oui mais on ce qu'on ne savait que
c'était le 28 kg rien oublié personne
programme et donc d'avoir les matches
qu'on a eue de ce retard et sable bon
alors pour le connecter donc on n'a pas
fait de colonne d'opinion au niveau
politique on a juste fait un bilan je
vais vous les pourquoi la fédé connectés
c'est pas par rapport marcone c'est par
rapport aux services faut savoir que nos
services se sont mis en avant
il ya des gens quand même dans nos
services à la ville de cosne qui se sont
mis vraiment avancé comme des soignants
et l'éducation nationale il ya beaucoup
de gens qui sont bien là et compris des
risques personnels 1 par rapport à ce
que vider à ce virus quand même qui
était virulent quand on voyait des
images à la télévision c'était quand
même impressionnant quoi donc je dis que
par rapport à eux on pouvait on pouvait
faire quelque chose c'est mon sentiment
après chacun a le droit d'avoir son
sentiment je voulais dire moi je dis que
quand on est chef d'entreprise et qu'on
veut féliciter son personnel on n'a pas
besoin de sortir un journal qui est
distribué à l'ensemble de la population
on peut le faire par des notes internes
bien sûr ah non mais tout est beau c
mais je vais vous dire moi est ce qu'il
faut est ce qu'il faut que le journal
municipal soient comptés dans vos
comptes de campagne c'est ça la question
en fait sur cet entre deux tours vous
avez l'impression que vous avez
l'impression que c'était à un document
alors réservé à faire campagne
c'est ça la question
le vrai collectif il était prêt depuis
un moment on a contacté l'imprimeur et
la primeur à papenoo la prime at on
voulu non plus lui est ce que vous savez
que vous comprenez tout ça est
abandonnée on l'a dit on a décidé de
faire un truc réduit et de leur demander
s'ils pouvaient nous le sortir assez
rapidement aulas commence à dépasser à
s'il pouvait sortir rapidement
comment vous lui avait demandé s'il
pouvait le sortir travail non celui la
veille de la sortie rapidement voilà
ok c'est ça tout simplement quoi donc
après non parce qu'on veut alors celle
de crise sanitaire
est-ce qu'elle l'a fait évoluer votre
vision de la vie votre vision de la
commune votre diagnostic sur la commune
c'est maintenant ce à quoi on va
s'intéresser parce que c'est finalement
ça qui décidera aussi les électeurs le
28 juin prochain
alain dherbier est ce que par rapport à
votre programme initial vous avez fait
évoluer les choses est ce qu'il y a des
éléments qui sont arrivés dans votre
programme ou que vous souhaitiez
renforcé parce qu'évidemment la vie a
changé alors si vous voulez de le faire
avait dit gouverner c'est prévoir et
nous on a fait un programme qui je pense
a rempli toutes les conditions pour
pouvoir gérer pendant six ans la ville
de cosne malgré la situation inédite
programme a été fait avant et toi mais
c'est pas ce qui ce qui allait se
produire
et bizarrement nos priorités la première
c'est la santé la deuxième c'est
l'emploi
le cadre de vie et la troisième c'est
qu'on est solidaire
c'est ce que vous reprenez et c'est sur
ce sur quoi vous allez nous interroger
on avait même un quatrième point qui
pour moi est primordial qui n'a été
repris par aucun de mes deux que des
dames et deux concurrents c'est compte
durable 1 parce que nous nous opposons
ford formellement
l'implantation d'une piscine à
belleville sur loire pour entreposer des
déchets nucléaires
on va y revenir et si vous voulez bon
quand je compare mon programme celui de
mes collègues parce que on a fait le
diagnostic
on connaissait les sujets qui devait
être prioritaire et on apporter les
solutions et les propositions pour ces
ces sujets
gadji gagnez vous avez évolué vous dans
votre programme dans vos propositions
par rapport à ce qu'on vient de vivre
alors notre programme en est le
programme n'a pas été modifié et a
mobilisé a été renforcée je suis
d'accord avec les trois clés de voûte
que vient de dire mme ce derby et qui
sont la santé l'économie et la
solidarité
c'est ce qui correspond aussi à
l'attractivité de cosne-sur-loire donc
la santé rapidement vous connaissez la
position de notre clinique
on attend une décision de l'agencé
régionale de santé concernant la le
redémarrage l'économie l'économie voilà
bon moi je sais le monde le sait le
monde bouge bien et quand on est
entrepreneur commerçants artisans on a
plus tendance à regarder vers demain que
de regarder derrière
donc il faut il faut rapidement rentrer
en contact avec les avec les entreprises
pour voir ce qu'il est possible de faire
d'abord savoir connaître savoir dans
quel état financier à sont ensuite il
faut pas simplement donner des
propositions comme ça il ya le conseil
régional qui a des aides pour les
entreprises il ya là comme la communauté
de communes qui a des aides et la gamine
elle peut faire quelque chose à son
niveau
bien sûr bien sûr mais je dirais il faut
pas il faut pas distiller des êtres
comme ça ils m'ont d'abord ça me paraît
clair il faut il faut être au courant de
dz que c'est les commerçants artisans
entreprises peuvent déjà avoir et nous
d'arriver en complément quand cela pour
cela est nécessaire
mais revenons aux mêmes questions est-ce
que vous avez évolué est ce qu'il ya des
points de votre programme que vous
souhaitez renforcer par rapport à ce
qu'on vient de vivre et on parlera
évidemment d'économie alors le problème
c'est que nous avions les yeux des
engagements avec un contrat de ville
avec livre habitat qui est prolongée
jusqu'en 2022
donc il ya déjà grassement donc il ya
des engagements financiers
à respecter quand on s'engage il faut
bien respecter en ce qui concerne le
coeur de ville je pense malgré la
semaine qui est de promotion qui a été
lancé par les ministres semaine passée
je crois qu'au niveau du coeur de ville
on aura des difficultés à mener tous les
projets à bien par rapport à ce qu'on
souhaitait faire dans l'ain pendant le
mandat on a l'impression que c'était
déjà difficile avant de d'être par
exemple commerçants dans le coeur de
ville de cosne sur loire et la crise
passée ça risque de faire des dégâts
c'est pas sûr c'est pas sûr parce que
vous savez des circuits courts où les
gens sont habitués à un peu à faire des
courses dans les petits magasins
aujourd'hui à cannes comme ailleurs veut
dire qu'il ya des aspects positifs à
cette crise on a redécouvert des choses
on va on a redécouvert la proximité déjà
et je suis convaincu qu'avec les
circuits courts avec nos commerces de
proximité on va arriver à redonner envie
aux gens de venir faire leurs courses
dans nos centres villes et dans nos
bourgs aujourd'hui convaincu alain
dervier sur cette question du coeur de
ville et finalement de la situation
économique de cosne sur loire qui
pouvait paraître fragile à certains
moments et qui avec la crise ne va pas
s'arranger certainement j'ai peur
qu'elle ne s'arrange pas effectivement
et c'est pourquoi il faut apporter des
solutions à toutes et toutes les
problématiques honda notamment le
commerce le connais un peu le serpent
qui se mord la queue il ya un problème
démographique ya un problème
d'infrastructures il ya installé tout à
fait mais si on veut retrouver de la
population
il faut qu'on ait des installations qui
permettent aux gens d'avoir envie de
venir avec la qualité de vie qui sont
chez nous c'est promet en premier lieu
un pôle de santé et puis ensuite le
commerce suivra les habitants arriveront
il faut savoir qu'aujourd'hui on est
passé en dessous du seuil des 10000
daily mail habitants c'est
catastrophique
vous auriez fait des choses différemment
dans le précédent mandat parce que vous
êtes de maire sortant si j'ose dire un
du précédent mandat et un du mandat
actuel qui scanne si vous voulez si si
je me suis représenté
bien évidemment c'est parce que j'ai pas
apprécié du tout le mandat que nous
venons de vivre
sur quels points sur sur quels points
sur le fait que nous n'avons pas pu
participer à la vie municipale comme
nous aurions dû le faire vos
l'opposition voulait bien oui parce que
l'opposition n'a pas été consultée n'a
pas été associée comme ils auraient dû
l'être
mais ça n'aurait rien changé jusqu'à
vendre et c'est la majorité qui décide
quand elle a été vous avez joué vous
avez été maire vous le savez messieurs
la majorité qui décide mais il ya des
choix qui ont été faits qui ne
correspondent pas du tout à coup comme
servier pendant votre mandat vous avez
fait des erreurs que nous certainement
c'est vous dites qu'on a fait des
erreurs
voilà c'est exactement la même chose
merci monsieur derby on encore on a
encore de l'histoire
vous le savez bien y compris les impôts
y compris l'achat d'un patrimoine et
autres on aplanit vous avez ras pas
articuler votre campagne précédente sur
la baisse des impôts 3% par an chaque
année et on n'a pas pu en fait vous
l'avez pas fait ben non parce qu'on a
une plage de rotation de ce derby de
l'étang de la part de l'état lors de la
13è si vous voulez bien que je termine
partant de là qu'est ce qui s'est passé
vous avez laissé espérer aux convois que
leurs impôts allaient baisser
en fait il p 280 mille euros de plus bon
non parce qu'il faut pas raconter
n'importe quoi
ils ont baissé de la bourse entre ceux
sur les six ans et vous aider à
augmenter de 9% demandé un administré je
peux j'ai regardé ça fait deux vous
allez voir point de vue sur les impôts
et puis parce que cette crise finalement
elle va obliger les collectivités a
abondé peut-être même à demander des
travaux à faire les travaux
supplémentaires pour aussi faire
redémarrer l'économie
il va bien falloir prendre en quelque
part quel est votre point de vue alors
moi d'un point de vue économique je
dirais que je serais plutôt positif que
cette crise
cette malheureuse crise peut nous
apporter quelque chose quand même sur
comme sur loire on a on a du foncier on
a des locaux on a des bureaux ont dit
qu'on est capable d'accueillir des
entreprises et on va pas on va pas
commercialisé le territoire aujourd'hui
on est à deux heures de paris par la
route par le rail on a la fibre qui
arrive je dirais quelque part il faut il
faut il faut développer notre territoire
commercialement il faut aller faire
savoir qu'on a ces choses là chez nous
ensuite sur le
sur l'opportunité d'aider des villes
moyennes on s'aperçoit que suite à cette
crise là mais alors on sera pas les
seuls sur nous allons dire que les
parisiens veulent venir vivre chez vous
les parisiens qui se sont retrouvés chez
nous pendant le confinement se disent
pourquoi pas se disent pourquoi pas on
est je me répète on est à deux heures de
paris par la route par le rail et on
commence à voir des équipements qui sont
qui sont importants alors au niveau des
impôts moi je veux pas rentrer dans dans
votre bagage non mais pour le prochain
mandat qu'est ce qu'ils font mais pour
le prochain
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire moi j'ai
l'habitude enfin c'est mon habitude en
entreprise quand j'arrive je veux savoir
de quels moyens je dispose où on est où
on l investissement
je regarde bien sûr les coûts de
fonctionnement et c'est moi il est très
clair on peut parler du centre-ville si
j'ai à investir demain j'investirais sur
le centre-ville c'est à dire que
contrairement à faire des très gros
travaux je pense à la troisième salle de
cinéma
contrairement à faire ça j'achèterai je
présenterai jeu je ferai tout pour le
centre-ville il faut rénover ses
bâtiments
il faut pouvoir les proposer à des
loyers abordables
parce qu'aujourd'hui les commerçants
d'aujourd'hui sont pas les commerces
d'hier va qu on avait le commerçant bas
l'appartement au dessus
non maintenant vous avez des gens qui va
le trouver un loyer entre 300 et 400
euros pour tenir pour tenir un petit
commerce donc alors c'est un
investissement à long terme je dis
souvent on va investir dans l'économie
comme ont investi dans la pierre c'est à
dire il faut pas un instant d'une
rentabilité immédiate
alors pour attirer les gens à l'an
dernier le disais tout à l'heure michel
venot il faut la santé évidemment un
pôle de santé qui tient la route
je ne blâme ans notamment sur les propos
de allez-y c'est de la compétence
commune de cette commune faut pas
l'oublier
et nous on n'aura pas les moyens une
ville comme caunes d'abonder au niveau
de la maison
je suis convaincu je connais les
chiffres ça fait quand même 35 ans que
je suis dans les affaires au niveau des
collectivités on n'aura pas les moyens
qu'on puisse monter une scène
immobilière
le projet monsieur gilles ollier au
niveau du centre-ville
je suis tout à fait d'accord c'est dans
notre programme que monter une scène
immobilière au niveau des commerces
il faut déjà convaincre les
propriétaires c'est pas facile vous le
savez moi j'ai dit il y en a pour deux
ou trois mandats
je suis honnête je suis fort et stable
dana voulait faire deux ou trois mandats
encore non pas moi non mais je veux dire
pour ce que ce que je veux dire c'est
que il faut pas se cacher derrière et
comme la communauté de communes c'est
quand même comme qui a le plus d'élus
donc si kona la volonté et arrive à
faire partager cette volonté la
communauté de communes c'est tout à fait
un an je suis d'accord mais j'étais déjà
j'en étais convaincu a manqué gérard
ailleurs ce sont les mêmes cellules pas
tout à fait quand même quelque 155
ribéry non mais bien sûr une chance que
je sais ce que je veux dire oui mais ce
que je veux dire c'est que les gens qui
votent au municipal vote aussi pour des
gens qui vont les représenter à la
commune qui recouvre tout à fait mais
après les décisions sont prises quand
même à la communauté de communes au
niveau d'un mot sur la santé pour la
santé
évidemment une grande inquiétude alors
je sais que vous allez rencontrer les
élus vont rencontrer l'agencé régionale
de santé au lendemain d'ailleurs du
second tour de ces municipales le 29
juin
aujourd'hui michel veut nous est ce que
c'est votre plus grand échec ne pas
avoir réussi à conserver la clinique
c'est pas de la compétence du maire de
cosne déjà un le privé c'est pas de la
compétence du maire de cosne c'est de la
compétence de l'état
avec donc l'entente qui avait le groupe
kapa avec l'hôpital avec l'hôpital
public c'est ça le problème c'est pas la
rétro cette vidéo de ce maire et publie
jeudi les ce soit michel deniau ou un
autre maire alain dherbier là il a vécu
aussi des périodes difficiles et les
autres maires dans les autres villes
c'est pareil par contre c'est bien
urgent et vital pour nos territoires
si on n'a pas de pôle santé on peut
parler au niveau développement
économique tourisme et autres on perd
notre temps c'est pas la peine de se
réunir si on réussit pas à remettre en
route ce pôle de santé je crois que
c'est peine perdue de vouloir faire de
la politique à cosne-sur-loire
c'est mon sentiment et on va y arriver
parce qu'on est presque hier on avait
encore un groupe qui vont s'associer
avec et à deux groupes qui souhaitent
s'associer pour monter un un groupement
de coopération sanitaire
je pense que c'est la bonne forme alain
dervier sur cette question de la
clinique qui aujourd'hui d'un mode
thermique pour la santé si vous voulez
j'en ai déjà parlé avec le maire sortant
très bien il faut parler aux électeurs
sur wii non mais qu'est ce qui se passe
la santé aegon
il faut revoir ce qui existe pour moi
vouloir faire reprendre cette clinique
c'est une erreur
pourquoi parce que on sait
du tout ce que le propriétaire de
l'avant d'un jour il est vendeur un jour
il est plus le prix on ne connaît pas
vraiment et il ya des travaux
considérables à exécuter donc ça c'est
compliqué pour moi l'idéal c'est tout
d'abord parce que ça regarde l'état
s'est tout d'abord de contacter le le
ministre de la santé et ce qui me ce qui
m'échappe
c'est que c'est le maire de sancerre qui
aujourd'hui dans la presse on voit que
le maire de sancerre qui trouvent que
qu'on traîne en longueur a réussi à
contacter par le biais d'un ministre il
va rencontrer le ministre de la santé
alors fort heureusement on a une
personne qui s'en occupe mais sa jeune
garde comme je ne suis pas du tout
d'accord avec eux ce qu'a fait monsieur
le maire et j'estime que là dessus il
était trop laxiste sur le pôle santé et
quand jouer et quand je vois des gens je
pense sérieuse que vous dites ans je
vois que monsieur n'est pas sérieux
c'est dire si je suis sérieux non je
vois de ce prix vous répondrais monsieur
pribyl qui est pratiquement une personne
qu'on n'arrive pas à voir ça fait quand
même huit mois que la chirurgie est
fermé il va venir le lendemain des
élections
de qui se moque t'on la descente est
tout à fait de qui se moque t'on il va
venir le lendemain des élections le
maire ne sera pas installé non hein
l'ancien maire sera peut-être en train
de faire ses cartons
et puis les présidents de communautés de
communes qui sont conviés ne sont pas
légitimes alors en un seul mot parce
qu'on va aborder d'autres sujets que je
laisserais michel veut nous répondre il
faut aussi que des régions ning donne
son point de vue votre projet pour le
pôle de santé c'est quoi il faut un vrai
projet public et points il faut la
construction d'un hôpital public
pour moi c'est ça sur l'ancien site de
l'hôpital avec tous les services autour
la maison de santé pluridisciplinaire et
un centre de périnatalité pour moi c'est
ça le projet l'amnésie launier votre
vision
de l'avenir de pôle santé alors mon à
vision de l'avenir du pôle santé d'abord
enfin je rejoins monsieur venu là dessus
on parle d'une clinique privée
l'intervention du maire je vais dire et
moi je veux une union sacrée derrière ce
pas pour se battre pour ce pôle de santé
les choses qui avait possibilité de
faire c'était oui de s'unir tous
différents et lutte différentes
collectivités ont pesé et de peser voilà
de peser sur sur la rs puisque bon
procédure judiciaire et un mandataire
judiciaire
et c'est la grèce qui va qui va décider
donc il faut faire pression sur eux
après d'avoir une grand projet pour la
santé oms est pourquoi pas mais on peut
pas le faire dans un état de désuétude
d'aujourd'hui c'est réaliste d'avoir un
hôpital public et à cosne-sur-loire un
vrai et grand hôpital puis comme le rêve
d'un moineau nettement après il faut
voir les choses se voir commencer par le
reconnaissant comme en live fonctionne
et la répartition des offreurs les
territoires et les fermer les hôpitaux
on repart sur la même chose est ce que
l'état et la côte et nous si l'état
n'est pas là à côté de nous c'est pas
possible
nice où qu'ils soient là michel louis
autres il faut il faut il et oui c'est
sont abattues sur la question de la
santé vous avez dit être là j'y
répondrai oui bien sûr que je me repose
mais nous on a travaillé en étroite
coopération avec tous les élus on a fait
un pacte avec tous les nouveaux
partenaires avec la population déjà avec
les manifestations des grosses
manifestations une adhésion totale de la
population
un des deux côtés de la loire ensuite
les élus notre comité 1 qui existe et
notre collègue de sancerre qui est un
ami
teasé je traverse téléphone ou trois par
semaine et c'est sûr que c'est lui qui a
eu le premier monsieur julien de
normandie au téléphone et tant mieux
tant mieux pourquoi je dis monsieur
dernier tant mieux ce soit lui le
canadien julien normandie jeu lors des
trois ou quatre fois pour le quart de
vie mais bon il a pu avoir le il a pu la
voir pour d'autres raisons avancées
l'eau je suis surpris que ces lumières
de 100 sièges bah ça ne dérange pas du
tout moi parce qu'on veut voir c'est de
la même équipe monsieur servier
oui on fait partie de la même équipe au
niveau du pôle santé on est là pour
défendre l'intérêt général de notre
territoire et notre bassin de vie et des
gens du sancerrois sont très concernés
pour mettre les boules sont très
concernés ils s'impatientent
alors béni s'impatiente on a bien
travaillé quand même je pense qu'on a
fait du très bon travail
après la rs chaque individu vous
connaissez dans les directions
régionales un chacun a son caractère et
monsieur prix bilila des services autour
de lui qui lui ont conseillé peut-être
avec avec la direction de l'hôpital de
nos mères peut-être de voir un autre
projet alors michel venu au hameau parce
que à la verbier on a parlé tout à
l'heure le projet de piscine
d'entreposage de combustible radioactif
usagé sur le site de la centrale de
belleville-sur-loire assez de l'autre
côté de la loire c'est pas dans le
département mais c'est tout proche
il y a beaucoup d'opposition à ce projet
la centrale c'est aussi un pourvoyeur
d'emplois sur le bassin de vie dont
niveau de tout regarder et il y à des
associations qui demandent aux candidats
de se positionner d'un mot vraiment
parce qu'on va passer bien sûr rameau
vraiment michel genaux quel est votre
point de vue ben moi j'ai pas trop de
points de vue parce que j'ai au niveau
des normes sécuritaires et où j'ai pas
j'ai pas tous les éléments aujourd'hui
donc je me positionnerai pas aujourd'hui
à 9 que ça veut dire que les électeurs
vont voter pour vous sans savoir si vous
êtes pour ce bassin d'entreposage de
produits radioactifs ou contre moi je
dis qu'aujourd'hui il difficile de se
positionner parce qu'on n'a pas tous les
éléments
au niveau sécurité daniel grenier moi je
vais vous dire l'autorité de sécurité
nucléaire pour l'instant dit il n'y a
pas de projet moi je suis quelqu'un
j'aime bien me positionner quand je
connais tous les éléments pour l'instant
les informations qu'on a les éléments
qu'on y revienne des associations qui
sont uniques le r qui sont nouvelles
tout à fait respectable et pour
l'instant on n'a pas les autres et puis
moi je pars aussi du principe que si le
site de la hague
bien sûr va va être plein à un moment on
le nucléaire on sait ce que c'est
c'est un peu comme toutes ses zones de
déchets tout on sait qu il va en falloir
mais il faut pas que ce soit chez nous
quoi alors un moment mais avant de se
décider je trouve qu'il faut avoir quand
même toutes les infos alain dernier vous
aviez déjà donné
votre point de vue cette question il
faut pas faire ce matin pour moi il faut
pas fuir le bassin pour caladons pour le
pour quelle raison parce qu'on n'a pas
suffisamment de notion de ce que ça va
engendrer
et puis je me rappelle qu'on veut
essayer de faire revenir des habitants
sur notre région
je me rappelle quand la centrale a été
construite tu avais faire les gens du
jour au lendemain
l'immobilier proche a perdu moitié de sa
valeur
mais ça cale en proie aux sciences ah
oui ça crée de l'emploi mais
l'immobilier a quand même perdu la
moitié de sa valeur
et puis non vous savez le fait de dire
on a pas suffisamment on sait pas
forcément ce que ce que ça va donner ce
que je sais c'est que par exemple la
centrale quant à elle a été construite
vous parlez de la centrale les travaux
ont commencé alors que le délai de purge
du permis de construire n'étaient pas
atteints c'est une grosse machine
il passe quelques fois un petit peu en
dehors des délais il attend pas
forcément
alors je vous propose de parler en
quelques minutes vraiment parce qu'on va
arriver au terme de ce débat de
stratégie et des lectorats avec ce
chiffre celui de l'abstention 54 4 % au
premier tour alors on imagine que vous
allez faire appel aux abstentionnistes
mais on aurait pu imaginer d'autres
stratégies par exemple michel venons on
aurait pu imaginer que votre ancien
adjoint michel mézy appelle à voter pour
vous avec ses près de 10 % de suffrages
et pourtant il n'en est rien aujourd'hui
mais michel michel mézy est libre il a
droit de penser comme il a été un
adjoint et d'axer son travail comme il
devait le faire normalement aujourd'hui
vous êtes toujours en désaccord avec lui
mais jamais en désaccord
là il a quitté votre majorité non mais
la kryte est en pleine crise sanitaire
vous rendez compte dans nos notes on a
lancé la crise sanitaire il est parti
juste à ce moment là parce qu'on nous
avait déjà la crise donc ça c'est pas
quoi je veux dire quand on est
responsable
quand on veut être maire d'une ville on
ne quitte pas le navire c'est mon
sentiment je vous le dis donc oui ce que
vous n'avez pas d'accord avec michel
mézy même
non non je pense pas mais je ne me suis
je connais bien je connais depuis qu'il
est arrivé à cause d'un garçon qui était
qui s'investit beaucoup pour le monde
associatif et puis la culture quoi voilà
c'est tout ce que je peux dire de lui
mais il a bien fait son travail il était
représenté bien la ville de cosne
pendant le mode à quoi mais il ya eu un
différentes nous juste une volonté de
pas de faire cavalier seul a eu de
différends entre nous juste une volonté
de faire cavalier seul tout à fait y'a
pas être différent alors en face de vous
il ya deux candidats qui auraient pu
aussi entre les deux tours travailler
ensemble peut-être dit-on daniel gillot
nier alain dervier vous auriez pu
imaginer un accord vous disiez au début
de ce débat daniel gillot nié je peux
signer les différents points de évoqués
par alain dervier parce que de fait il
semble qu'il ya quelques quelques points
de convergence moi j'avais été très
clair bien avant ce deuxième tour
j'avais été très clair pour la campagne
du premier tour ou lors de mes réunions
publiques j'avais annoncé la chose
suivante j'avais dit si je finis
quatrième ou si je finis 3e décollé du
second je rentrerai chez moi j'ai
terminé deuxième tout proche de monsieur
venot je pense avoir une liste unie
compact et quelque part je ne voulais
pas je voulais respecter la parole
donnée aux électeurs donc voilà après
monsieur dernier a décidé de maintenir
sa candidature non il n'y a pas de souci
il a le voilà il a le droit il a le
score pour le faire y avoir un troisième
temps il faut il faut savoir jeter a
précisé quand même c'est le fait du
maintien de la candidature de monsieur
derbier peut permettre éventuellement à
monsieur venait de repasser alors que
pendant six ans il a critiqué sa gestion
donc voila moi je suis là les électeurs
nous ont fait confiance les résultats du
premier tour sont là et puis fusionné
pour gagner c'est une chose gérer une
ville pendant six ans en est une autre
moi j'ai besoin d'une majorité solide
compacte qui pue ce qu'ils puissent
gérer pendant six ans à l'interné c'est
vous qui allez vous avez entendu d'avoir
gagné michel gély j'ai entendu ce que
vient de dire
d'une peur michel venu en disant qu'il
est en très bons termes avec michel mézy
qu'il est parti comme ça parce qu'il y
avait un virus
j'ai quand même rappeler pendant encore
je vais quand même rappeler que pour moi
michel mézy rapidement michel mézy ne se
porte se reporte pas puisqu'il apparaît
avait été disqualifié il apparaît à
voter pour quelqu'un c'est pour moi le
seul qui présentait un programme qui
tenait la route et qui était très proche
du nôtre et le premier point des
programmes de michel mézy
il est parti en bons termes et il
demande un audit financier et fiscal de
la mairie de caunes donc j'y trouvais
que ça a été bien gérée donc ça veut
dire que vous dites c'est la main même
si il a fait parti de droite stratégie
politique en sicile avec administratif
mais ce dernier s'il avait pas été pour
rappel des risques on va vous laisser
une minute on va vous laisser une minute
puisqu'on arrive au terme de ce débat et
on a choisi de vous laisser une minute
de conclusion un sablier virtuel
s'égrènent rats derrière nous durant
soixante secondes et votre ordre de
passage a été désigné par tirage au sort
et c'est vous
michel venot qui débutait pour une élite
de conclusion alors moi je lance un
appel à toutes les caunois doc aux noix
aux courses oiseaux course pour qu'ils
puissent se déplacer pour venir voter
dans des bonnes conditions
nous allons mettre en place dans les
tous les bureaux de vote bien sûr les
règles sanitaires
recommandé par la rsa et les madame la
préfète pour que chacun puisse se sentir
en sécurité sanitaire voilà ce que je
voulais dire alors sinon les gens ils
ont aussi possibilité de donner
procuration des gens très proches de la
famille et tout ceci pour vous dire que
je souhaite que les gens participent à
cette élection
c'est très important ça démocratie s'en
sortira grandie moi j'estime que nos
anciens ont se sont battus pour le droit
de vote
malgré cette crise malgré ce terrible
qu'on a eu pendant ces trois mois et
demi je crois qu'aujourd'hui les gens
doivent se ressaisir soif d'or se
déplacer s'ils le peuvent
je les encourage de le faire et à venir
venelles et bien sûr pour l'avenir avec
vous merci michel venu où la parole est
à vous à l'an dernier pour votre minute
de conclusion
alors mes chers concitoyens le 28 juin
sera une nouvelle élection
votre vote sera
capital vous aurez à choisir entre trois
listes
la liste du maire sortant qui pour moi
est capitaine abandonné
pourquoi parceque il a été abandonné par
huit de ses élus dont le premier adjoint
quant à la gestion catastrophique
c'était ça me fait penser à les copains
d'abord la deuxième liste quand d'autres
comme de vous à nous c'est une liste où
j'ai essayé de rassemblement pour mettre
fin à la gestion de monsieur nous
malheureusement pas de d'accord possible
et pour moi c'est je marche seul
quant à moi et ça c'est ma différence à
moi c'est avoir une liste qui est
renouvelée expérimenté et qui saura être
performant dès le premier jour
chers concitoyens merci de la confiance
que vous importerez merci alain dherbier
une minute de conclusion pour vous
daniel gilles oignons ok la confiance
que vous nous avez témoigné lors du
premier tour de ces élections
municipales et communautaires nous
confirme dans notre projet il existe
bien une nouvelle voie pour gérer la
commune de cosne sur loire
nous n'avons pas le droit de revenir en
arrière il nous faut un nouveau cap
il nous faut un nouvel équipage nous
pouvons ensemble dans la concertation
la participation la transparence relever
ce défi aujourd'hui on découvre à
nouveau le potentiel et l'attractivité
que peut avoir une ville comme la nôtre
il ne faut pas passer à côté de ces
opportunités devant vous je m'engage à
défendre les intérêts de notre ville est
vrai pour qu'elle prospère et qu'il y
fasse bon vision c'est vous le 28 juin
qui allait décider de ce que vous
souhaitez faire
nous sommes là nous avons un programme
et nous sommes prêts à travailler pour
vous merci merci daniel gillot nier
merci alain dherbier merci michel venot
d'avoir participé à ce débat c'était le
premier à cosne cours sur loire pour
donner le nom complet pour ces élections
municipales merci à tous d'avoir accepté
le principe de ce débat place maintenant
au choix des électeurs le 28 juin
prochain
merci à vous de nous avoir suivi la
campagne électorale elle se poursuit
bien sûr sur france 3 prochain débat à
demain soir à 10
heures avec les têtes de liste d'
avallon dans l'yonne restez avec nous
dans quelques minutes le 19/20 avec
arnaud lefebvre belle soirée à tous sur
france 3
[Musique]